Speaker 1: Today's arguably the most packed show
of the year, and it almost didn't happen. I'll
explain why on the bonus show. But if you're
hearing this, if you're seeing me right now,
then we managed to get the show done. And now
let's talk about s v B Bank. Silicon Valley Bank.
Silicon Valley Bank has collapsed. And while
when we look for reasons connected to reality,
we find not enough regulation taking too much
risk miscalculations by bank executives as the
reasons why this happened, the right has
found their villain and their villain is
Wokeness Wokeness is why the ultra capitalist
SBB bank has failed. Let's listen to this was
one of the first people to make this claim. This
is Republican Congressman James Colmer. Where else
than Fox News explaining woke is why it failed.
Speaker 2: And then we see now coming out that
they were one of the most woke banks in
their in their quest for the ESG top,
top policy and investing. If this could be
a trend and there are consequences for bad
Democrat policy. And I think we need to keep
an eye on all the the banking sector right now.
Speaker 1: Yeah woke and Democrat
policies are why SVB Bank failed now
he was ridiculed by anyone who has a shred
of common sense, but he doubled down on it.
Speaker 2: They were a woke bank. If you look at
their director of risk management, she brags about
their diversified ESG portfolio. And the problem
is that a lot of this is fantasy land. It's like
the Green New Deal. It doesn't work, it doesn't
pencil out. And if you're a bank being insured by
the federal government, which is the FDIC, your
responsibility is to grant loans to people who
can actually pay them back, not just to people.
Speaker 1: All right. So he's continuing the woke
bank thing. And it wasn't only James
Colmer, Fox News host Jesse WATTERS,
and many other Fox hosts as well, although I'm
not going to play every single clip he also went
with. This is it's not only a woke bank, it's
a woke Biden bank, which is a whole new thing.
Speaker 2: When the Fed chair finally
raised rates, the bank got crushed. Well,
why weren't they paying attention? Silicon
Valley bankers awoke, woke Biden Bank. They
were holding seminars on Lesbian Visibility Day
and National Pride Month. Now, if you want to
hold a Pride month, that's fine. But you got to
be able to chew gum at the same time and walk.
So keep an eye on the balance sheet, guys.
Speaker 1: There you go. Well-known finance
analyst Jesse Waters, and then Trump's former
whatever speechwriter, adviser guy Stephen Miller.
He also says Wokeness Wokeness is the problem.
Speaker 2: Or weeks ago, the Biden sign that says
equity or Defi is the core mission of every single
agency in the federal government. In other words,
they want to run the country the way the
executives at Silicon Valley Bank ran. That
financial institution take huge, risky gambles
on crazy world projects, crazy climate project
virtue signaling with no financial integrity,
no financial soundness underneath. And this
whole country is going to go the way of Silicon
Valley Bank if we don't change direction.
Speaker 1: All right. Woke is the problem.
Now let's go back to reality. Who is more to blame
than Biden for what happened? Well, it's not about
blaming any one person, but failed. Former
President Donald Trump is definitely more to
blame than is Joe Biden. Here is video of Donald
Trump in 2018 with Mike Pence standing behind him
doing that stupid smirk as he always does. Trump
in May of 2018 announcing that he is rolling back
so-called crippling Dodd-Frank regulations, the
very regulations that could have prevented this
particular collapse. Trump bragging about it.
Speaker 3: We've done, but we've kept yet another
promise. As I signed the Economic Growth,
Regulatory Relief and Consumer Protection
Act. Right. It's a big deal. A big deal for
our country. This is truly a great day for
America and a great day for American workers
and small businesses all throughout the nation.
Speaker 1: Is it?
Speaker 3: The legislation I'm
signing today rolls back the crippling Dodd-Frank
regulations that are crushing community banks
and credit unions nationwide.
Speaker 1: They were. And of course,
Silicon Valley Bank was a bank
subject to those regulations,
which Trump bragged about eliminating. So
Trump And the lack of regulation, of course,
is partially to blame. We found out that Silicon
Valley Bank was actually operating without a chief
risk officer for almost nine months in the period
of nine months ending in January of this year. The
bankers miscalculated risk. They were overextended
on tech at a time when tech was struggling. And
what we have here is not wokeness hurting the
bank. It's the bank's decisions, hurting the
bank and lack of regulation, because it turns
out a lot of these businesses don't have that
incentive to regulate themselves. They said, let's
take a shot. Let's not let's not play it safe.
And then now they want to be
bailed out. And importantly,
there's a difference between bailing out
depositors and bailing out the bank. And
that's a subject that we will talk and talk about
in the future. But folks, woke is not to blame.